je suis tout excité là j'ai envie de
vous faire partager un peu mon
excitation avant même de vous dire ce
dont je vais vous parler en fait vous
êtes excité ou pas cenal ça vous est
excité ou pas fait résonner un peu cette
jolie salle 1
vous savez de quoi je vais vous parler
tout excité comme je suis deux millions
de morts
en fait être l'ambiance direct en fait
rigoler pas il ya des types aux états
unis qui bosse là dessus et en fait
comme il manipule des millions de morts
tous les jours ils ont rappelé à un méga
mort voilà l'ayguade d'imaginer la
conversation à la machine à café
qu'est-ce que tu faire je suis en train
de compter les méga mort de la journée
maintenant il ne plaisante pas c'est
vous pouvez regarder mais gadzhev les
gens qui bossent sur les armes de
destruction massive il compte en méga
mort s'il ya une attaque ce sera et
pourquoi je vous parle de ça après tout
c'est pas tellement l'intitulé de
montaut que megan or passé parce qu'en
fait c'est intérêt pour les méga mort
m'est venue un jour où un gamin m'a posé
une question toute conne comme beaucoup
de gamins le font d'ailleurs idriss
elle a servi à quoi la première guerre
mondiale vous êtes jamais posé cette
question elle a servi à quoi parce que
la première guerre mondiale si on devait
mettre une étiquette pour un prix ça
serait dit cette méga morts 17 millions
de morts donc on peut légitimement se
demander à quoi ça a servi quoi dire et
donc voilà j'étais là en train de
cogiter mer sert elle a servi à quoi
tend à temps ah bah elle a créé la
deuxième ça marche pas à quoi qui a créé
la guerre froide ensuite que ces taxis
ainsi un commercial venait vous disais
de gérer un projet j'ai un projet bon
ils coûtent 17 millions de morts vous
direz je vais réfléchir quand même non
vous demanderez ce que vous auriez en
échange
alors j'ai cherché un vraiment je vais
être honnête avec vous j'ai cherché
pendant des années et la meilleure
meilleure invention de la première
guerre mondiale que j'ai trouvé
c'est le trench coat nom me chercher
parce que la voiture on l'avait déjà
l'avion on avait déjà le lance-flammes
vois pas trop en quoi c'est intéressant
le gaz moutarde non plus en tout cas le
gamin je l'aurais pas convaincu avec ça
par contre c'est le trench coat beach
bon alors j'avoue c'est quand même le
vêtement le plus cher du monde parce que
c'est un vêtement qui a coûté 17
millions de morts alors encore une fois
ci un commercial se pointer vous dis moi
j'ai un projet à 17 millions de morts
vais demander bon bah c'est un trench
coat non mais c'est quoi en plus la fin
de vie la drize la fin de la malaria la
paix dans le monde
un écran plasma in dr pepper j'en sais
rien pour 17 millions de morts quand
même on peut demander des trucs c'est
plus que c'est plus que tous les
sacrifices humains dieu on leur
sacrifier voilà tu sacrifies une vierge
à la pleine lune et est à la peine dans
la ville
ok deal mais mes 17 millions de clients
quand même dur alors voilà ça m'a amené
à me poser la question me dire que par
la guerre
c'est une très grosse arnaque en fait
c'est que quand un vrp il vous vend 17
millions de morts
regardez ce que vous avez en échange
c'est pas la fin d'illettrisme à la faim
de la malnutrition la faim du palu un
vaccin contre le sida
c'est juste d'autres morts plus tard en
général et donc le le vrp le jean claude
convenant qui vous vend la guerre il se
fout de votre gueule en fait et bien
plus si ce vraiment une ville vous
arnaque quoi
c'est la plus grosse arnaque sur terre
alors je vais vous parler de cette
arnaque parce que la question c'est pour
l'instant la guerre elle nous arnaquent
nous mais comment nous on pourrait
l'arnaqué elle alors pour assimiler un
peu cette idée je dois d'abord vous dire
un message très très très important et
ce message c'est que toute révolution
dans l'histoire de l'humanité qu'elle
soit politique philosophique morale
scientifique ce que vous voulez toute
révolution si c'est une révolution
elle passe forcément par trois étapes
d'abord c'est considéré comme ridicule
ensuite c'est considéré comme dangereux
et ensuite c'est considéré comme évident
ridicule dangereux évident prenez le
droit de vote des femmes sur 300
personnes des buts il ya toujours
quelqu'un dans la salle pour dire non
mais c'est encore ridicule aujourd'hui
nicole vous trouverez une cagette de
tomates mûres sous vos sièges
non mais sans déconner 10 789 ces
dangers ridicule bon c'est ridicule
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et la citoyenne dans tout ça
n'en écoute bobonne j'ai du boulot
laisse moi tranquille je vais tellement
prendre cher la fin de ce pays et parce
que autre truc ridicule maintenant dans
les salles il ya aussi des femmes
ton idée 1889 cent ans plus tard c'est
dangereux qui va garder les gosses et
faire la vaisselle
non parce qu'au bout de cent ans
commence quand même à se poser les
vraies questions je veux dire bon
aujourd'hui les femmes votent and so
what
c'est évident ridicule dangereux évident
l'abolition de l'apartheid ridicule
dangereux évident l'abolition des
esclavages ridicule dangereux évident la
terre est ronde
ridicule dangereux évident la terre
tourne autour du soleil l'électricité
l'informatique la physique quantique le
big bang ce que vous voulez si c'est une
révolution c'est fastoche ça passe
forcément par ridicule dangereux évident
à tel point que si c'est pas ridicule
c'est pas une révolution
la réciproque n'est pas vraie toute idée
révolutionnaire est forcément ridicule
mais toute idée à la con n'est pas
forcément révolutionnaire
bon bah voilà l'idée révolutionnaire que
je voudrais vous présenter moi et elle
commence là ça c'est un parasite la
toxoplasmose et la toxoplasmose c'est un
parasite des chat de la souris et de
l'homme et c'est un parasite qui une
fois qu'il est dans notre cerveau
élimine un peu la peur
par exemple quand il est dans le cerveau
d'une souris il l'a fait aimer les chats
se parle il vraiment malin il fait que
quand il est dans le cerveau de la
souris elle adore les chats elle adore
l'odeur de l'uriné de chat c'est dingue
et les humains qui en la toxoplasmose
supporte beaucoup mieux loti
de l'uriné de cheval a tonné le veau
pour dit mais du coup qu'est ce qui se
passe évidemment quand une souris se met
à aimer leur hymne de chat tôt ou tard
elle se fait bouffer quoi et c'est
exactement ce que la toxoplasmose
voulait puisque elle son but c'est
d'infecter le chat donc c'est un
parasite qui arnaquent la souris et le
chat ils arnaquent le perdant est le
gagnant et il a tout compris ce parasite
quoi que quoi qu'il arrive il a gagné
lui eh ben il ya un autre parasite comme
celui là j'aurais comparé un peu c'est
ce parasite à un autre parasite qui
infecte l'humanité depuis quinze mille
ans et qui gagne tout le temps quel que
soit le camp lui s'en fout de savoir qui
gagne ce parasite et vous aurez bien
compris que ce parasite
c'est la guerre la guerre elle en fait
que les deux quand elle s'en fout elle
gagne la souris le ch a annoncé pas son
problème
elle son but 7 buts et un maximum
d'êtres humains moi je suis biologiste
alors j'ai tendance à étudier des choses
sous l'angle du vivant tiens comment
commencerait cet organisme la guerre si
on la considérait comme un organisme pas
ça sera un parasite vachement efficace
vachement vachement efficace alors voilà
la question
imaginons que l'humanité soit parasité
pas par la toxoplasmose qui après tout
fait beaucoup moins de morts 1 quand on
regarde mais par la guerre l'a ainsi la
guerre est une maladie question peut-on
la soigner mais avant de la soigner il
faut diagnostiquer plus important c'est
de vérifier qu'on est bien infectés par
ce parasite alors un diagnostic très
simple je vous ai dit que la guerre
était une arnaque
je vous ai mis d'un côté l'université de
stanford et une demi une des universités
les plus cool sur terre et de l'autre je
vous ai mis un drone et c'est quoi le
point commun à votre avis entre ces deux
trucs il coûte le même prix en fait
c'est dire que le vrp qui vous vend pour
17 milliards de dollars
tu peux avoir un drone ou l'université
de standford je vous comprenez qu'on est
en train de se faire baiser ou pas là
donc là vous savez qu'on ait infecté
jusqu'aux yeux parce que quand on décide
de claquer 10 7 milliards de bastos dans
un dans un programme de drone un seul
dire c'est juste le drones prédateurs en
l'occurrence plutôt que la l'université
la plus sexy et cool au monde
on a un problème on a un vrai problème
est bon comme pour l'alcoolisme
la première étape c'est de d'admettre
qu'on a un problème alors en fait je dis
pas que faire des armes c'est idiot un
bien au contraire faire des armes en
général c'est pour les esprits les plus
brillants de leur génération
archimède il faisait des armes léonard
de vinci faisait des armes
tesla y faisait des armes nobel faisait
des armes et même einstein faisait des
armes
donc qu'est ce qu'on peut en tirer ça
comme conclusion pas le virus de la
guerre il prend ce qu'il ya de mieux
exactement comme la toxoplasmose va
s'implanter dans un endroit précis du
cerveau le virus de la guerre dans
l'humanité il s'attaque à ce qu'on a de
mieux
toujours à travers toutes les époques de
l'antiquité à nos jours
en fait je suis pas le premier à avoir
10 arias ce psychologue william james
qui a dit les humains ils sont capables
des meilleurs prouesse quand il s'agit
de tuer autrui pas ce qui serait bien
c'est qu'il soit capable des meilleurs
prouesse quand il s'agit de sauver
autrui et c'est vrai que toutes les
qualités qu'on développe en temps de
guerre et en temps de paix on les
développe pas ya eu the new york avait
dit ça aussi parce qu'il avait vu le
débarquement en normandie il avait vu
toutes les prouesses techniques qu'une
armée en mouvement pouvait réaliser et
cette équipe a finalement ce monde en
armes qu'on a créés c'est lui qui a
parlé de complexe militaro-industriel ce
monde en armes qu'on a créés ils
dépensent de l'argent mais ils dépensent
aussi les rêves de ses enfants et le
génie de ces scientifiques qui aurait pu
être appliquée à autre chose
du coup jimmy carter en 77 et dis moi ce
que j'aimerais c'est qu'on rame arrive à
unir nos efforts pour construire et pas
pour détruire comme si on était en temps
de guerre mais pour construire pas pour
détruire
au fond ce qu'avait dit tous ces gens là
c'est ça serait bien qu'on ait des armes
de construction massive pas des armes de
destruction massive
alors vous vous rappelez peut-être de
cette histoire on a envahi l'irak parce
que prétendument ils avaient des armes
de destruction massive
c'était pas le cas mais je vais pas
juger d'autant que là vous avez un ted
speaker saviez peut-être pas mais ce
monsieur a fait un tête et là je vois
pas du tout je vais pas commencer à
juger et simplement la seule question
que j'ai posée c'est qu'ils utilisent
qui est ce que c'est la guerre qui nous
utilisent ou est-ce que c'est nous qui
utilisons la guerre parce que j'ai un
vrai doute en tant que biologiste
j'ai un vrai doute qui a domestiqué qui
ont pas que c'est nous qui avons
domestiquer la guerre mais si c'est l
inverse
ça mérite de se poser la question or
depuis que ce gamin m'a posé la question
de l'utilité de la première guerre
mondiale va je vous avoue que je me la
pose cette question
alors évidemment moi j'ai voulu
présenter un remède au virus de la
guerre il est ici dans cette petite
fiole je vous en parlais un peu plus et
ce remède c'est un 7-1 contre virus à la
guerre en fait c'est un un anti
parasites
évidemment je vais vous aspergez avec ça
va être particulièrement érotique tout
ça c'est enregistré sauter d'un on est
d'accord ça va finir sur youtube tout ça
bon vous pourriez me dire ouais ok
l'armée son boulot c'est pas de
construire un l'armée son boulot c'est
de détruire vrai ou faux faux ça c'est
une construction militaire
ces neuf brisach en france bien avant le
pentagone j'aime bien sûr ça c'est un
magnifique octogone et bien avant le
pentagone nous les français comme
toujours
eh bien on avait fait ça et c'est une
construction durable et solide mais
c'est un fort au départ donc l'armée
elle s'est construit et quand elle s'y
met c'est joli en plus et ça dure donc
elle sait construire bien mais elle sait
aussi construire vite ce que vous voyez
là ce sont les fameux port mulberry qui
ont été déployés en 24 heures pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
il fallait aux alliés un port en eau
profonde parce que cherbourg avait été
détruit par les allemands
eh bien les alliées boom ils vous ont
fait un port à 24 heures parce qu'on est
comme ça chez les alliés ont fait des
ports en 24 heures et non mais
franchement en quoi l'armée elle sait
construire bien et elle sait construire
vite
donc franchement l'art mais bon elle est
là des innovations par exemple le radar
le radar c'est l'armée 1
le satellite ça a été développé par
l'armée aussi les moteurs de jet
toujours l'armée les semi conducteurs
encore l'armée et bien sûr l'ordinateur
donc au fond à chaque fois qu'une
innovation militaires passent dans le
civil elles changent le monde et elles
changent le monde mais en profondeur
quoi donc ce serait bien d'en faire une
un principe systématique ça serait bien
que ça arrive tout le temps qu à chaque
fois une novation militaires elles
doivent passer dans le civil internet
bien sûr ça aussi ça vient du militaire
alors là je vous ai mis une carte du
monde qui le monde la nuit quoi plus ou
moins enfin nous mêmes totalement
d'ailleurs et la question à se poser
c'est qu'est ce que c'est qu'une super
puissance c'est quoi une superpuissance
au fond si vous ouvrez un bouquin de
géopolitique ça vous dira qu une
superpuissance c'est un pays qui a un
grand territoire et une grande
population connectée tous les deux il
faut que le territoire soit connecté il
faut que la population soit connecté
donc c'est pas du tout avoir des armes
de destruction massive un être une
superpuissance pas du tout la corée a
des armes de destruction massive c'est
pas une superpuissance
le pakistan a des armes de destruction
massive c'est pas une superpuissance
pour être une super puissance il vous
faut une grande population connectée et
un grand territoire connectés et ça ça
relève des infrastructures et les
infrastructures c'est la capacité à
construire
par exemple l'inde bah c'est pas une
superpuissance l'inde
elle sait qu'elle a besoin de connecter
sa population pour être une super
puissance c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait
une tablette pas cher ça n'a pas très
bien marché mais elle a voulu faire une
tablette pas cher parce qu'elle a
compris que le premier
la première priorité qu'elle avait
c'était de connecter sa population et la
chine
bah c'est pas une superpuissance non
plus parce que son territoire n'est pas
connecté et c'est pour ça que la chine
investit dans les trains à grande
vitesse
mais aux états unis pendant ce temps
barona le pentagone et le pentagone ses
740 milliards chaque année 740 mire avec
un dixième de sa part en vous éliminez
la malnutrition la malaria l'illettrisme
et vous réaliser tous les objectifs du
millénaire pour le développement c'est
ça qui me fait dire qu'on est infecté
par le virus de la guerre alors moi ce
que je dis c'est qu'il nous faut un
complexe militaro-industriel 2.0 le
pentagone tout ça on appelle ça le
complexe militaro-industriel et bien
j'aimerais qu'on en ait un nouveau une
évolution de ce complexe
militaro-industriel je veux pas qu'on le
détruise
je veux qu'ils évoluent et voilà mon
idée au 20e siècle le pouvoir
c'était quand vous étiez capable de
transformer une belle planète bleue en
planète rouge
ça c'était le pouvoir du 20e siècle si
vous aviez la capacité de transformer
une belle planète bleue et verte en
planète rouge
eh bien vous étiez puissant et ça
s'appelle les armes de destruction
massive bien mon idée c'est qu'au xxième
siècle le pouvoir ce sera l'inversé
la capacité de passer d'une planète
rouge à une planète bleue
et ça on l'a pas encore dans ce cas là
la planète que vous voyez c'est mars et
on parle de terraformation la capacité à
transformer une planète morte en planète
vivante et bien ça c'est une arme de
construction massive et on ne l'a pas
encore mais avouez que pour l'instant
c'est quelque part entre ridicule
dangereux évident
l'objectif c'est que ça devient évident
le plus tôt possible
heureusement on a des gens comme elon
musk qui aujourd'hui disent j'aimerais
bien mourir sur mars mais pas à l'impact
j'aime bien ce mec c'est ça le complexe
pacifique aux industriels et c'est ça
mon virus
ce petit virus là c'est l'idée qu'un
jour on pourrait unir nos forces pour
construire plutôt que détruire c'est
martin luther king qui citait cette
histoire au début quand ulysse a voyagé
il ya eu les sirènes et ulysse voulait
entendre les sirènes alors il s'était
attaché au mât pour pouvoir les entendre
sans est séduite par elle mais
finalement l'équipage du lys s'est dit
plutôt que se boucher les oreilles on va
faire venir orphée orfei chante très
bien et donc il va couvrir le chant des
sirènes et quand on entendra orphée on
en aura plus rien à [ __ ] des sirènes
ben pour martin luther king c'était ça
or fait c'est la paix et les sirènes
c'est la guerre et si on trouve quelque
chose qui nous unit davantage que la
destruction on aura plus d'attention à
consacrer à la destruction
et bien voilà mon virus vous avez vu son
adn
vous saurez leur expliquer et vous
saurez le propager
pour vous merci